good morning it's tuesday so something
you might not know from having watched
my last couple of videos is that this
has been the most stressful two-week
period i have experienced
in a while there are many many
advantages to making a video every
tuesday like for starters it gives
structure to my week without
vlogbrothers i am
not sure that i would even know it is
currently tuesday
also in order to be creative i need
accountability and discipline which
weekly videos provide and i get such a
strong sense of encouragement and
connection from the conversations within
this community and i feel
really lucky to have a strong sense of
community especially right now
plus making one thing every week even
though it takes a lot of time and energy
and so on
actually makes it easier to make other
things because i am forced every week to
think about what i am thinking about and
why i am thinking about it like a lot of
the ideas in my books got their start
from vlogbrothers videos as did many of
the essays in the anthropocene review
book
but the big downside of making something
every week is that you can't necessarily
talk about how you're actually doing in
the moment like a family member of mine
recently had kovid which for a variety
of reasons was very scary but i didn't
want to talk about it here because
one i've learned over the years that
once you share something you can't
unshare it and also too i don't really
feel comfortable sharing news about
other people and three i didn't yet know
how serious it would be or
if anyone else would get it so i am here
inside of my world having a difficult
experience but then when i go to make a
video i'm not necessarily ready to talk
about it so i have to
uh pretend i mean of course the central
trick of the social internet is that
whenever you make something you
choose what's inside the frame but as
viewers the rest of us can't help but
believe what's inside the frame because
it's literally
all we can see like like like i like
like i have all these speech
particularity like like i have all these
speech particularities that means that
it takes like 45 minutes to record a
four minute video
but you don't see any of that i i i
i cut all of those i cut i i cut all of
those so
i i cut all of those i i cut all of
those so that to you
it doesn't seem like i stutter or trip
over my words but that's not
real that's the frame and i have to
confess that i find participating in
this simultaneous romanticization and
commodification of experience a little
nauseating but i also
don't know how else to handle it like if
i take a week off that also raises
questions but also i don't want to take
a week off because i benefit from making
vlogbrothers videos in all those
aforementioned ways
so i don't know maybe the best strategy
is to try to call attention to the frame
at least some of the time and to
acknowledge that a lot of stuff in fact
the vast majority of stuff
happens outside the frame side note this
is one of the reasons i still use jump
cuts in my videos it's a little visual
reminder that there is time between when
i say
x and when i say why it's an attempt to
acknowledge the existence of the frame
whereas videos that are filmed without
jump cuts often feel very
natural to me but in a way that i know
ultimately is
inauthentic now that everyone seems to
be okay and the crisis has
hopefully passed it is easier to talk
about but even so i realize that by not
going into detail it feels like there's
a mystery that i seem to be
teasing i know that i can't help but try
to puzzle through similar things when
they pop up in my subscription box but
again this is something i
don't know how to find my way through
because i want to be able to tell you
that the time is difficult
without violating anyone's privacy so
yeah that's
all i wanted to say really i don't know
if it's possible to remember
that there is a frame i know that i am
constantly forgetting it when i'm online
but there is one this hasn't really been
a video so much as it has been
a question how do i navigate the
labyrinth of the social internet better
if you've got answers let me know but
for now i have to get back to work
because the last edits for the
anthropocene reviewed book are due in
three days which is the other thing
that's a little bit stressful
nonetheless
i am glad that i made a vlogbrothers
video this week
and thank you for being here hank i'll
see you on friday